I'm curious if you're close to Liam
Neeson I've hung out with him a bit he
is such a fantastic guy oh yeah are you
guys like good friends have you bought
yeah I mean it's been almost nine years
and I was kind of a kid Oh on the first
one and it was like the best fake movie
dad any girl could ask for he's so
protective in real life too he helped
you with a prank
I believe we meet this is an old
boyfriend that you played a prank on yes
I yeah so there was this boy and it was
kind of whatever I was a little bit
heartbroken and he was kind of a hot
mess and I was telling Liam about it cuz
he always asked about my love life
um or lack thereof and and he was like
this this just can't be like we have to
set this kid straight like what should
we do and so we called him it is us you
actually recorded and we have it this is
a real prank
Liam talking to a guy who hadn't maybe
treated his boy if an ex-boyfriend who
maybe didn't treat you as him I love
this take a listen
you're lower than the past comma so I'm
just gonna say this once can lead to us
face your first mistake was dating out
of your league
your second mistake well let's just say
any more mistakes and I'll break your
other arm see lonely I don't need to
stay up at night at the particular set
of skills wasted when you have both do
you get your [ __ ] together
[Music]
[Applause]
you